if the the US dollar is no longer the
world reserved currency what's next like
we're seeing what happened with with
brick or bricks to not to preclude South
Africa from that what would happen don't
open that kind of words because we've
been talking about this dedolarization
theory on our channel for months now and
it is true that
the world is becoming de-dolarized yes
kind of there's more trade happening in
non-dollar denominated uh currencies so
you're getting oil deals done in renambi
or Chinese Chinese or stuff like that is
one or whatever Russian Ruble or
whatever you want to call it
But ultimately that Chinese one is still
picked to the US dollar now
is the dollarization happening it's a
process that will take many many many
many many years but what is the
alternative so okay cool we decided we
all decided we don't want to be part of
the US dollar where are you going to go
you're gonna go to China you think China
is a better option in the United States
look maybe the USA isn't perfect but let
me tell you China is not much of a
better option I don't think you want to
be in the South African currency it
hasn't got a great track record you
certainly don't want to be in the
Turkish lira
so where where are you you want to be in
the Russian currency
so the problem is that the the dollar
right now is the best of a bad bunch
but and in order for D dollarization to
happen what you need is you need for
there to be a better option because
otherwise as capitalists people will
hold on to their money and say even
though this is bad
that option over there is a little bit
worse it's still government counterparty
risk yeah now look we've taken the
orange pull so for us we see Bitcoin and
we look at Bitcoin and say look you need
to have a certain percentage of a
portfolio in a neutral money that's not
linked to any country that's linked to
an algorithm and a mathematical formula
but other than that and again I put the
question to you guys and said if there
is the dollarization and you guys are
forced to do dollarize
where are you gonna put your money yeah
yeah but but and the answer is you're
gonna rather be in your studies yeah
when you go back and I I agree by the
way and I think that we are definitely
in the process of de-dollarization
that's that's without questioning the
dollar is absolutely losing its Reserve
currency status but that doesn't happen
overnight it doesn't happen over years
that happens over decades decades and if
you go back to the last World Reserve
currency the British pound that started
losing its dominance in the 1920s when
they came in in 1944 in Bretton Woods
that just kind of the icing on the cake
right and so what you see is you never
have a global Reserve currency that is
implemented by decree that you have a
king or a Putin or whatever come in and
say from now on we are using this Brix
new currency what happens it's always
Bottoms Up
so those entities within that economic
system say hey we want to do more
business with the United States going
back to the 1920s right because the U.S
is growing and growing and growing we
have more business we have more
customers there so we want to hold more
more dollars on our balance sheet and as
the U.S economy grows as a percentage of
global GDP so does the use of the dollar
and that's how it happens so the bricks
or Chinese Juan or whatever yes over the
long run it will overtake the dollar but
it'll only do so as that that economy
overtakes the United States economy as
far as a percentage of global GDP so I
saw a chart of uh GDP of the G7 versus
GDP of bricks and if you look at the GDP
of the G7 it's a chart that goes like
this and if you look at the GDP of
bricks it's a chart that's going like
this yeah well the trend is there but
still as a percentage it's still heavily
favors the Jews so I don't know if
you've got if you've got that chart it
was a tweet by Gabor go back gerbeck's I
think is his name
um and he shows the chart that does that
and that and it I mean the trend you can
see of when you look at it in isolation
it's nothing but if you look at it in in
in
um over a long period it's actually
quite a scary chart because bricks is
going up and and the and the G7 is going
down and the two crossed a long time ago
kind of kind of like that I also saw
some stats that showed the GDP of China
relative to the GDP of the US forecast
for 10 years from now unlimited it's
scary because the rate of acceleration
in China versus the decline in it versus
the US is it's it's a very there we go
so that's the that's the line that I was
talking about the red line is the brics
countries the blue line is the G7
and that's GDP and that's going from
1995 to 22 to 2025 now the lines of
crust
okay you were talking about people
wanting to hold the currency of the
economy that was growing in GDP there's
your number there's there's your chart
there's your chart you've got the brics
countries growing in GDP you've got the
G7 going down the biggest economy in the
G7 is is the US yeah so the only other
equation is that uh dollars nominated
debt which is future demand for dollars
and how rapidly you know are looking at
another chart of global uh debt
denominated in dollars outside the
United States as you start to see that
decline from let's say 70 percent down
to 65 you're seeing the dollar lose
Reserve status in real time but but what
the mistake people make here is they
when they look at this uh equation and
probabilities is they only focus on
dollars being on the asset side of the
balance sheet and they forget that
dollar liability is on that other side
and that creates future demand for those
dollars and if the banking system
contracts if we have a global slowdown
in economic depression those dollars are
going to be harder to come by now people
say that oh my gosh the fed's going to
print money and the feds and we're going
to do all this money printing that's
fine but how do those dollars get
outside the United States you see the
way they get outside the United States
is the trade deficit well that's fine
that's 1.2 trillion per year but you're
looking at a global economy that needs a
hundred trillion dollars or that has a
hundred trillion dollars in it you know
so that's just a drop in the bucket so
um it's go ahead just try and look for
um I'm just trying to think there's
there's another chart we could actually
show you what percentage of countries
are holding US dollars as part of the
global Reserve or something like that
and what you'll see is that over time it
has declined yeah but that's central
banks so central banks yeah yeah I agree
but I think you really got to look at
the private sector there and then to do
that that's why I like looking at that
uh that debt because it includes the
debt on the balance sheet of the private
sector so I think what we can agree on
is that
dolorization should happen yeah then it
is happening and it is happening the
problem is that there's no viable
alternative currency right now that
could displace the dollar so if you as I
say in order for detolarization to
happen you've got to have a viable
alternative you you're basing it on
trade right now there is no brics
currency and if there was one United
brics currency maybe we'd see a
different story yeah and you've got to
have something that interrupts the
network I mean I know you're a crypto
guy so you know how important networks
are well that's and and there's there's
never been a more powerful Network than
the dollar correct never ever ever when
you include the euro dollar system and
the global banks that are on dollars so
how do you you penetrate that you know
that's that's the growth level of bricks
versus GDP may be ahead but size Wise
It's not yet population wise bricks is
obviously yeah
that's why I wanted to find it bricks is
yeah the size of population it's not
even close but in in in in regards to
GDP the G seven still has uh brick speed
but growth is exponential growth is
exponential you can you can by the way
the one that is going to drive it even
and they're not going to slow I don't
think it's going to slow down anytime
soon I think India is going to continue
to to do what they're doing so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
foreign